The next uh presenter and presentation
promises to be a lot of fun. Uh at least
that's what I'm saying right now. Um
I've just met uh Abby Giles Hay and I
can say I can promise you that it will
be fun because um she's a very fun
person. Uh she is the analytics and
innovation director at Capgemini uh with
a PhD in computational modeling and over
15 years of data analytics and AI
experience. Abby has worked across
various industries and projects
including healthcare and improving
patient care. But today Abby will share
with us how video and graphs are
transforming sports analytics. So, how
cool is that? Uh and how these
technologies are reshaping team
performance and player development. So,
um let's welcome Abby.
>> Hi.
>> [applause]
>> First of all, congratulations for making
it to day two. Who's still awake?
Woo! Awesome. Who came for the Python?
Who came for the property graphs?
Who really came for the football?
There we go. See, we know where we're
at. That's fine. We We had to start
there. Okay. So, as you can guess, I am
a seasoned presenter, so feel free to
fire tomatoes at me from the back.
Happy?
Or fire questions at the end. Either or.
Um we're going to go very quickly
through video analytics and property
graphs. Um
because this has been live streamed, I
won't be naming the club that I'm
currently working with. If you want to
know and you really want to know, ask me
outside the doors at the end.
Okay good.
Okay, so you had the quick intro. Um
yeah, so my background is uh I am an AI
person, machine learning. Don't hold it
against me, okay? I know that generative
AI keeps coming up. I'm not one of them.
Okay?
I'm not.
I did AI before it got all sexy and they
decided to call it the 21st century
sexiest job.
Um I had a computational modeling of the
human heart up in Newcastle.
And we did computational modeling for
autism. AF.
So autism.
I can't even say AF. I need more coffee.
Uh came out of that, decided I didn't
know what to do with my life, I became a
junior database administrator, as you
do. I learned the Oracle database the
hard way.
From the security, okay? And the
licensing.
Apart from that, it's all easy.
Then I went into public health care um
and private banking, so I've done some
work in the fraud analytics space um and
I'm also an ACE director. I'll come back
to that in a second.
Um I am part of the ACE program, so I'm
an Oracle ACE advocate, so I advocate
for Oracle technology. That does not
mean I'm going to do a sales pitch. What
it does mean is I keep Oracle on their
toes. My job essentially is to push
their technology and call them out when
they get it wrong.
That's my job.
Okay.
It all starts with data.
80% of the world's data, and in some
cases as high as
It's the fun stuff.
It's where all the cool context lives.
But with all that unstructure,
it's also very difficult to deal with.
All right. So, that's the first
challenge here.
I work in the world of football.
It ain't structured.
There's humans involved, there's balls
involved, there's weather, and there's a
referee.
It's always fun. Makes my Sundays and
very, very, very fun.
But in there
is complex to deal with, but in there is
a lot of context and things that we can
use for our players.
So, I need a business question. I always
start with this, uh whether it's data
science, property graph, it does not
matter to me. What is the business
problem or opportunity I have? Where am
I going to get that data from?
Is it AI ready? Is it graph ready? Is it
even data?
What analytics am I going to provide?
What are the insights? And I only really
get to know about through dialogue,
feedback, and review, so that I can have
actions, my players improve, and get an
outcome, better results.
So, let's have a quick catch-up on the
story so far.
This team in the picture is Wallsend
Boys Club.
I said boys club and they're all women.
You're probably thinking, "What the
hell?" Anyone heard of a player called
Alan Shearer?
Okay, he is an ex-Wallsend Boys Club
graduate. Alan Shearer, Premier League
goal scorer for those who don't know,
massive Newcastle United player, still
lives in the northeast, and now appears
on BBC a lot.
He used to be one of our players.
When I joined Wallsend Boys Club, they
didn't have a girls program. So, one of
the first challenges I had was setting
up the girls program.
Um when I left Wallsend, and hence why
you will come and ask me the question,
"Who are you with now?"
When I left Wallsend, essentially, they
had a full girls set up of three women's
teams.
However, there's a challenge here.
Wallsend is based in the northeast, in
Newcastle. One in three families there
are below the poverty line.
So, they're earning a lot of money.
In came
a thing called COVID.
Now, I'm a football coach.
I need people, I need players, I need a
pitch.
And we got hit by lockdown.
And I also looked at our analytics, and
I love sports science, and I love data
science, and I love graphs, and I love
all the cool maths that goes behind it.
So, I set myself this challenge, a
ridiculous challenge. I said, "Can I
bring Premier League analytics to
grassroots football?"
Oh, but for less than $500 a year.
Insane?
Possibly.
In the midst of COVID? Very insane.
So, essentially all I've got is video
of my teams playing games. That's it. I
don't have any players. I don't have
anyone to test this on at the minute.
That's what I've got.
So, I started off on the journey.
So, the original version starts like
this.
I've just realized how old these slides
are.
Okay, the original version started like
this. So, to do this, you need to teach
a machine what is a person.
Okay?
Literally have to sit, and you have to
click each frame of the video and say,
"That's a Man City player. That's a
Chelsea player. That's a Man City
player. That's a ball. That's a referee.
That's a goalkeeper."
With 4,000 images later,
and I've drained the entire coffee in my
house,
you get the idea. So, I'm trying to
teach the machine what a player and what
teams look like.
So, version one looked like this.
Maybe not so good, right?
USA versus England.
Kind of getting there. Referee's playing
for England. Happy days. Always helps.
How many goals? One.
Uh and the football's not detected at
all.
Ooh. Version one down the pan.
Not great.
Catch up so far. Okay, so this version
was version two. We have moved on from
that, but this is version two.
Now, I can detect the players.
I can track them. They have an ID.
I can put them as a position on the
pitch. Not always accurately, as you can
see. So, what you're seeing in the
bottom left
is essentially their rough XY
coordinates where they are.
Now, it's not always getting it right,
and you're probably thinking, "Okay, why
is it not getting it right?"
What we're doing here is a type of
homography matrices where we're looking
for the boundary of the pitch, and then
we convert it from 3D to 2D, so XY
coordinates. It's a bit like a scatter
graph.
Doesn't always get it right. It's going
to get coaches.
Again, not quality.
The other one that I always get asked
is, "Well, you've got tracking IDs, why
don't you just look at the shirt
numbers?"
Most of the time I have a fixed camera,
and they might be turned the wrong way.
So, I've got some shirt numbers. So, I
needed a new way to track them. So, we
have a tracking ID.
What you've seen there is 200 frames per
second,
but back together again.
So, every frame we do this, we find the
position, the XY coordinate, and we
store it in a database.
So, essentially what I'm doing is
bringing structure to the unstructured.
And I'm storing that into a database.
So, if I go back,
as it's going through and doing each
one, finding each player, and it's kind
of doing all of this. Now,
you're probably at this point going,
"Okay great.
What's this got to do with football?" I
get where you're going. What's it going
to go do in?
A guy called Rudd is the first guy who
ever really looked at football
analytics.
And he was a beloved Swindon fan
watching Bristol.
And they were playing Bristol, and and
they would not score a And he just had
enough. They were lackluster. They
weren't attacking. They weren't doing
anything. So, he grabbed a notebook pad
and pen, and he started making notes.
And the notes were, how many times
attacking were they versus how many
goals they scored? So in that game, they
had 147 attacks and only one goal.
Not great.
And he said, "Well, I'm going to look at
the whole of Swindon's games for the
next sort of five games." And he found
that on average, 280 attacks with two
goals.
And he discovered that if he just
improved them by 0.71%,
he could make it go from two goals to
three goals.
That is the first basis we have of
football data collection.
He was structuring the game.
So in the sense, what I've done is
automated his world
but in positions.
He was very much understood because
essentially what he'd understood about
the data was about attacking play.
He later got tagged as being a long ball
coach because he focused on that
attacking nature.
In a sense, I'm going to
look at one particular part of the game.
Football analytics is about looking at
different aspects. I can look at the
player themselves. What's their body
position? Left foot, right foot, height.
How fast can they accelerate,
decelerate? How fast can they turn,
jump?
They're all physical dimensions of a
player.
I can then look at the team shape.
4-4-2 4-2-3-1 4-3-3.
5-3-2.
They're all formations.
So we can look at the team shape.
So I need to work find a way to connect
player to team,
team to player.
So one aspect that we need to look at is
passing.
Pass the ball.
It's quicker. It's quicker than someone
running or dribbling with the ball.
And passing effectively changed the
game.
For a very long time, passing was not
actually part of the English game.
And it was actually introduced by the
Scots.
So the Scots would beat the English
all the time because they passed the
ball.
English FA decided to change the rules
and put passing in.
Now England could beat Scotland.
I know. Sorry to any Scottish people
here.
So,
when we look at the art of passing, we
can look at the player where they pass.
We can look at the location that they're
passing from.
But we can also look at patterns of
passes.
So let's move on to that.
This is what we mean by passing
patterns. Sterling is going to pass to
Cancelo. Cancelo is going to play A
THROUGH BALL TO KEVIN DE BRUYNE. HE'S
GOING TO GET ON THE BALL. HE'S IN THE
18-YARD AREA AND HE SCORES.
We've all seen that on a Saturday
afternoon.
Yes?
Well, it's essentially a pattern, isn't
it? If we think about it in a very
simplistic property graph,
players are nodes and passes are edges.
It's exactly what I did with the data.
Because I've got every frame, including
the ball, the ball location, the player
location. I know which player is in
there.
I've essentially trained machine
learning algorithms to look at the play
and tag whether they are dribbling
or passing.
So now every row in the database not
just has an XY position of the player,
but we have an event. An event being
dribble or pass.
So that means now I can filter my data
and say I just want to look at passes. I
want to look at passes in the game.
Node node edge.
We've got a property graph.
Everyone happy now? So we've GOT PYTHON,
WE'VE GOT PROPERTY GRAPH, and the
football fans are still with me, which
is good.
Okay. So if we do that for all of the
passes in the game,
that's one game.
So we can add another column.
Now we can do all of the passes
throughout the entire season.
Ooh interesting.
Now we got all sorts of patterns coming
out.
What do I mean by that?
If you want to have a go at this, you
can do it yourself.
The structure that I ended up building
turns out someone else did it. Course
that's one, okay? They have a load of
free data available and you can do it in
Python. You can put it into your own
graphic base. You can go off and do it
yourself.
This is where you can get it and this is
the open data. The structure I'm talking
about is event data. They kind of are
the masters of event event data.
So their structure is very similar to
what I've done.
I'm just going to go back to this.
I said that I wanted to do this for $500
or less.
You're probably looking at me at the
minute going, "Okay, I can understand
doing it in Python, open source, easy."
Doing all of that image processing on a
laptop,
that's going to get messy quick.
And you keep talking about a database.
You're right. When I started out in the
pandemic, I used the Oracle free tier.
So it's completely free and the Oracle
OCI free tier.
So so far, free and free.
I'm under $500.
As we got further into the season, we're
processing processing every single game.
I had to up the OCI usage CPU, okay? And
essentially, that meant there was a lot
more
data going through.
To process one game, talk about 8 hours.
So we did it on the OCI.
Every row into the database, we were
coming up with just shy of 2 million
rows per game
on average.
When 23C came along,
at first I ignored and thought, yeah,
it's going to cost. Don't want it. They
had a developer edition. I thought, you
know what? I'm going to give this a
shot. The reason being
in 23C, Oracle changed and had property
graph as part of the database as a data
type.
So, now, not only did I have the
relational data, I could literally
display it as a property graph, and I
can search it as a property graph.
So, we can do things in there.
>> [clears throat]
>> Look at the number of passes received.
So, player, team, number of passes
received etc.
Looks a bit horrible in terms of what's
going on.
This is StatsBomb data, just in case you
want to go off and do it yourself.
What we're looking at is a specific
match.
We're looking for an event that happened
in four, less than four. And you're
probably thinking, what do you mean by
that? I said I'd put a tracking ID.
It's the same in the StatsBomb.
A player might receive a ball, but then
dribble it, and then pass.
So, that dribbling is another event.
So, receiving is one event, dribble is
another event, pass is the next event.
So, there's four hop four events, if you
like.
So, I've said it within less than four
events,
they passed the ball, and ordered by,
and that's how we get the the groups.
We can also look at who and which teams.
Alex Greenwood, Millie Bright, Keira
Walsh.
But then we get to fun things like this.
So, this is where we get to real
property graph, and it's the patterns.
So, when we're with the players, what we
really look at is something called
passing patterns.
And when I say we spend
hours doing passing patterns, I'm not
exaggerating.
Every warm-up, every technical will have
one of these in.
So, it could be center half just to
winger to full back into the striker,
into the center mid, and into the goal.
And they'll practice that. Why?
Technical passing ability.
Two predictability.
Your teammates know where they need to
be in the event that the center half
picks up the ball.
We take the unpredictability out of it.
Reactions. They know how to react and
how to get off the defender.
They know where the next ball, the
through ball is going to be.
So here
>> [cough]
>> she's going to play the ball up.
This receiving player is looking for a
back.
And then she is looking for a through
ball or an overlap.
And this pattern is called an up, back,
and through.
It's used by clubs all over the world.
So, that's what we're looking for in the
data. We're looking for an up, back, and
through pattern, or a pattern that they
do repeatedly.
How would I do that? Well, I just said.
Every time we found a player in the
video, we got the XY coordinates. The XY
coordinates is location.
Location is context.
And the context can be searched. So, we
can look for properties on nodes
where it goes up, so the X axis goes up,
it goes down, and then it goes through.
Where the starting player and the end
player are different.
Make sense?
Ooh, that just looks horrible.
What am I meaning? Up. So, there you go.
Start is less than end. End
is less than the second middle point.
Sorry, sorry. The end is further forward
than the middle point. The the start
player and the end player are not the
same, and the in the index is less than
10. I mean, there could have been some
dribbles in between.
Whoa, okay. England versus Australia in
the World Cup to prove to you that I'm
not lying. That that that video I just
showed you was not me just making stuff
up.
>> [snorts]
>> This is how many up back and throughs
happened in England versus Australia
in the World Cup, in the Women's World
Cup.
To prove to you, I extracted one line.
In the 3rd minute and 47th second, Alex
Greenwood, Rachel Daly, and Ella Toone,
and Lauren Lauren Hemp will be involved
in an up back and through.
So, grab the actual footage.
No cheating.
I don't like the magicians that don't
show the tricks.
I like to show the tricks.
Okay, so at this point, we're going to
pass backwards.
Ooh ooh ooh ooh ooh. No,
she's not going to do it.
Oh, it's going forward. It's going back.
And up, that's not through.
Let's go sideways. Oh,
that's not an up back and through.
3:36, we're getting close to it. Come
on.
Always sideways. Always sideways.
Here we go. Up.
Back.
Through.
Proved it.
Now then,
why is that important?
I showed you this video through
annotation.
I'm a video analyst at a club now.
I'm no longer at Wolves end. I'm a video
analyst at a club now.
And essentially what we're looking for
are these clips to show the players.
Now, you can imagine if it's a new
passing pattern, not an up back and
through, something more complex, we want
to know how many times they successfully
did it and how many they did not do it.
Was it on the left wing or was it on the
right wing? Was it through the center
or in the defensive half?
Well, that would mean I would have to
sit and watch the video all of the time.
Well, actually we've just proven that I
don't anymore.
We can count the number of up back and
through. So, I can count the number of
complex patterns.
I can do the top matches in game. So, in
our season, I can look at the top
matches in the season.
And all of this
in my database
is actually quite performant.
Why? Cuz I've got the relational
database.
So, I can do it on time.
And then just look at the matches
individually.
I can look at the front half of the
season versus the back half of the
season.
I can look at things like
playing through the thirds. So, from
defender to midfielder to forward. Can I
find those combinations?
These are all simple patterns, but you
can get the gist that we're looking for
the more and more complex patterns
throughout the entire game.
So, here we're looking for defense
players.
We're looking for a midfielder.
It's going to get into the midfielder.
We're looking to now play through the
the lines. So, play through the thirds.
So, from the defensive third to the mid
third.
Doesn't have to go to another center
mid. It could go somewhere else first.
Center mid. Then we're looking to play
through to the striker.
All of that is found in the data.
Because not only have we got the XY
coordinates,
the tracking ID at the beginning, I said
I couldn't see shirt numbers. That was a
problem.
So, the only challenge so far that I
have to do manually
is when the video's first lined up on on
the first frame, it puts an ID on every
single player.
And I have to have an input screen where
I go in and say, "ID 10 is player nine."
And put the player's name next to it.
That means I can then use my reference
data in the relational database look if
they're a midfielder, defender, or
striker. So, playing through the thirds
just became a lot easier.
After all of that, I annotate in a tool
looking like this. That enables me to
give them information.
Why is that important? Why? Going back
to my business problem
why is that a thing?
Originally, the average time for me to
do all of that that you've just
described was 3 days. So, play on the
Sunday, we'd upload it, we'd process it,
I'd watch it, I'd find the parts to
snip, I'd then annotate, I'd then
package it, and then I'd present it to
the players. 3 days.
So, they would get it at best Thursday.
Which meant they had Thursday, Friday,
Saturday to put it right for Sunday.
Now, we can do it in a day and a half
because I can search for what we need in
the property graph.
Annotate the videos.
Means they get it on Tuesday.
So, they now have Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday to put it
right.
Business problem?
Can it be done for less than $500? Yes.
Does it save time and energy? 100%.
Where is it going?
It's done weekly.
We do all of that, and we do the other
normal BI stuff.
So, average position on the pitch, left
and right wing tax.
All of that, and the property graph,
means it makes my job a lot easier as an
analyst.
We all have to make trades, time, money,
processes.
Don't trade your data away. I could have
thrown that video data away and not
thought about using it and the
instructional nature of it and how
difficult it was going to be.
Please don't trade it away.
And hopefully, you've had at least half
an hour's breather.
I haven't gone complex on grass, but
you've enjoyed a bit football time.
Thank you very much.
>> Awesome. Thank you very much. I think we
have uh time for just a couple questions
and we're going to Yeah, go ahead right
there. Yeah. No, you Andre. Yeah.
>> Thank you very much for the talk. That
was really interesting. Uh so, maybe
this is an open-ended question, but like
what are open problems for you right
now? And another question is what is the
state of the art in terms of going from
the analytics side, which is I query and
observe this happening, to the more
optimization side, which is what do I
need to do to exploit the possible
vulnerability for that certain team?
>> Yeah.
Okay.
Um I'll go with the possible first uh
and things that I couldn't put inside
it. I know I'm online. This is probably
dangerous.
Um
I said that we look for patterns that we
do.
Reverse it. What if I could identify you
the key player in a pattern
And what if I could tell manager that a
bit
4 or 5 days before the next game?
What if we could then do training
patterns
that exploit that weakness?
I can't go any further details than
that. What was the first question?
>> Open problems for you. What can't you do
right now that you wish you could do?
>> Open problems. What am I working on at
the minute? So, one of the other things
cuz I do a lot of work with the
under-21s
um and and how we progress them through
kind of
their ability to learn because
we don't want to be in the transfer
market all the time. We want to advance
our younger players as quickly as
possible. So, my under-21s have had a
crash course lesson in AI, which was
quite interesting.
Uh and they're very, very data-savvy
now. So, they'll come and ask me, "Ooh,
how many shots did I have? How many
passes did I have?" It's brilliant
because like I've gone from these
16-year-olds that knew nothing about
data science
to literally they all have their own
dashboard that they log in and look at
now. So it's it's pretty awesome on that
side. The open problem we have at the
minute is for each player they get an
individual player development program
every month.
That takes hours to write.
So my open problem at the minute is can
I create a LLM that uses our language
for football,
takes their data and puts it all into
their player program.
So I are we pushing boundaries? I think
so.
>> Thank you.
>> [snorts]
>> All right. Thank you. Thank you. I think
we're going to leave questions for
there, but please find Abby. I think
we've got um I hear
does it say networking? This isn't
drinks later. So um find Abby later with
your questions.